la deuxième bataille d'Ernani n'aura pas
lieu alors que s'ouvre l'année Hugo qui
célèbre le centenaire de la mort du
grand poète Antoine vitèse présente en
ce moment même au Théâtre national de
chillot la mise en scène qu'il vient de
faire de l'œuvre théâtrale maîtresse de
Victor Hugo vitesse dont le travail a
souvent causé scandale ne risque guerre
cette fois-ci d'être contesté il est
hugolien jusqu'au fond de l'âme comme
l'a constaté Jean-Louis
Magalon apprends-moi secret de vaincre
et de régner et dis-moi qu'il vaut mieux
punir que
pardonner der Nani il y a l'histoire un
roi don Carlos devient empereur et il y
a aussi l'amour par Dieu nous verrons
bien si je suis roi d'Espagne et des
de pour rien Seigneur oh par pitié quoi
vous êtes Altesse vous êtes roi du
chesse ou marquise ou comtesse vous
n'avez qu'à choisir les femmes de la
cour ont toujours un amour tout prês
pour votre amour mais mon proscrit je
vous suivrai
don sol la femme tant convoité c'est Jan
Gastaldi une des comédiennes féties
d'Antoine vitèse si elle repousse dans
Carlos c'est qu'elle aime Hernani le
bandit l'aventurier que traque toutes
les polices du royaume et qui finira par
périr comme elle victime de la parole
donnée à un vieillard archaïque trop
jaloux du bonheur des amants la tête d'
du roi pour l'instant mais on dit qu'il
est
mort sans
moi grâce au ciel il est mort le rebelle
on peut se réjouir maintenant chère
belle allez donc vous parer mon amour
mon orgueil il y a une femme pour trois
hommes et
d'ailleurs cette femme est au centre de
toute l'histoire et et c'est intéressant
ça cette pression exercée par tous les
hommes sur une femme la nécessité du
théâtre c'est de faire entendre
l'inouï faire voir l'invisible et jouer
l'injouable pasamour que tu meur non je
ne le veux pas je
l'ai tiens
maintenant mon père tu te vend sur moi
qui
t'oubliais des douleurs
étranges j' loin le Doig
Antoine vit est à son affaire et le
spectateur à la fête vieille passion de
sa jeunesse l'uvre de victorug lu comme
un plateau de thè de fantasm aès les nu
Men et l'inant promette d'un ciel étoilé
le soleil pourrait enfin se lever mais
dans le théâtre romantique il est
toujours trop tard